the concept of improving lives runs
through the center of everything I do
and then I realize that the way to
improve lives is to continually improve
yourself
so with that every morning when I get
out of the bed I haven't fixed
everything in the world yet so there's
always something to do I read an
interesting quote for Buddha he said
that good people have to get out of the
bed every day and try to empty the ocean
with a ladle of new that was profound
and I paused for a second and I said I
what the hell is a ladle okay like a
spoon try to empty the ocean with a soup
spoon as a mentality of how you wake up
every day to try to do good in the world
I'm really driven by continually trying
to elevate my mind and elevate my spirit
and care for my body and to be able to
love as many people as effectively as
possible with this mystery of life that
I've been given we didn't grow up with
the sense that where we were was where
we were going to be you know we grew up
with the sense that where we were almost
didn't matter because we were becoming
something greater you just watched two
amazing clips from Will Smith take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life belief
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]